ukrainian ambassador the uk is with us
um again this morning friend of the show
now it's good to see you thank you i'm
just asking you while we were listening
to deborah why it's keith now rather
than kiev yeah that's what told that
this started with this sweden at that
time its vikings so the name was key of
the guy
okay who's founder that key is key of
now okay and now it's keith um thank you
very much indeed for explaining that to
you mr ambassador and also um
to explain what on earth
is happening as far as intelligence is
concerned suggesting that your country
could be at war today it doesn't appear
to be you can imagine this relief among
ukrainians that were not under immediate
and a full-scale attack we've been in
war for seven years so people sort of
grew a quite thick skin but at the same
time imagine that helicopters will fly
the rockets will fly
everything tanks will roll over and they
bother it was something unbearable for
people now at least for today we have
some sort of relief we ask ourselves
what would be what would come tomorrow
in the day in the months
the intelligence seemed to be very
specific that it would be
today
it has proven it would appear to be
false
what do you make of that to be frank it
was not intelligence written by
intelligence it was a report of the
journalists that they know about
intelligence that's saying and so on and
so forth so about this american
intelligence it's american intelligence
but it was reported by the americans new
american newspapers nobody came with you
know report intelligence it was ia and
it's saying that you know we have 16th
of this month
what i believe is maybe the intelligent
services of the united states and the
nato allies were trying to warn putin
that they know about his plans on a
particular day of attack and it helped i
hope so
what are you making of reports of a
de-escalation on the borders
we observed the discoloration some of
this relation still not enough to see
that it's actually they're moving them
back they started moving around but at
the same time they bring some other new
fresh troops towards our border so this
message is still mixed and i believe
that the decision hasn't been made by
him yet and he has all the options open
let me i would like a quote to you
president zielinski uh in a facebook
post um that he'd been told that
february the 16th will be the day of
attack and then we were hearing um from
an unnamed senior ukrainian official um
saying that the comment was ironic and
sarcastic um
what
what should we take seriously and what
should we see as sarcasm i believe it
was sarcastic because president zilensky
was telling for quite a while that our
intelligence is not confirming immediate
immediate threat and imminent attack on
us what president zilinski was doing
today he was he announced the day of
unity of ukrainians so ukrainians were
were coming by the way even here in
london they're coming united to show
that we are not threatened we will do
whatever we planned for ourselves
meaning at this particular timely
political choice which is west
democratic choice
now i've been a bit confused about what
you've been saying about joining nato of
course nato ministers meeting nato
representatives meeting in brussels at
the moment you've made a few i think
it's fair to say i'm sure you're
clarified for his conflicting comments
in recent days about ukraine and nato
you said ukraine would consider backing
down on nato to prevent a war then you
said um it wouldn't so so what just to
clarify that it was very unsort of uh
not very clear message on my side when
the journalists asked them i never said
the journalists fault that's what i find
the journalist that's easier i agree
with you but you know this particular
case there was statement not mine but
journalists who asked me who would you
contemplate what ukrainian game
contemplated to considering dropping
this and instead tell him no we are not
considering which is true we are not we
have a constitution and so on so so i
try to explain to him why we are doing
it why we are so stubborn because that's
the questions i receive each and every
day from even here from people
why you're so stubborn as ukrainians why
wouldn't you listen to putin and so on
and so forth my explanation is first
it's official it's our constitution it's
our
made deal so so many many years ago
second there is no anything better than
nato in our part of the globe we took
something best out of possible options
and we can stay neutral because it will
be into our existence
even if not joining nato means that the
country security will be more
safe
we can't provide it we don't have any
paper to sign we signed so many papers
with russians already and none of them
were respected we can't expect them to
respect anything else signed on paper
but
the suggestion is even from the german
chancellor who was in i think speaking
to putin just yesterday he was hinting
at the suggestion that ukraine would be
safer if it didn't join nato
i don't understand how we can be safer
already because your nato friends and
allies will uh always have your back but
if you join then it's seen as a further
incursion uh towards russia as far as
putin is concerned i'm just putting his
point of beauty frankly speaking
ukrainians are watching how nato is
reinforcing their own borders and you
know when you under the threat of attack
and you're asking who's coming to help
and everybody's telling you openly yeah
we're coming but not to you we're coming
to defend our own borders if you
collapse if you die we want to be on our
own border so ukrainians don't
understand how nato being outside of
nato can be helpful
knowing that you're already under the
umbrella this is something but staying
next under the rain names staying next
to umbrella is not actually helping
i like that analogy are we closer or
further away from war today than we were
yesterday i do believe that we're close
at least we had the psychological year
is over we understand that actually war
is not imminent it was said we can
overcome it we can't come to some
peaceful solution and this is compromise
but it's not in the nato that's what i
discussed with journalists it was one
big sentence but compromise is in the
minsk agreement so-called which our
people are negotiating with russia
directly it's not like west only working
for us and helping us and we're just
sitting and waiting until the resolution
no we're doing our part the compromise
is not easy in minsk agreements not in
nato what do you want putin to do apart
from movies trips away obviously well
frankly yeah we wanted him to get back
to whatever he was and we actually by
the way we can start again trading we
can start again flying to each other we
can start doing things the the
psychological drama the trauma which has
been brought by him and so many lives
already lost we'll have to long long
long time to heal but when neighbors
will live in this part of the globe
nothing we can do with our neighbor but
you're more relieved this morning than
you were yesterday
i'm optimistic at the same time i'm i'm
realist i'm a diplomat i understand that
this can be also games we will you know
get relaxed and tomorrow the attack will
come so we we have all the options open
our our people in the borders they are
preparing for the war as well okay thank
you mr ambassador thank you thank you